joseph mcbride is a professor of
screenwriting and film history at san
francisco state university
a veteran television and film writer and
longtime journalist mr mcbride is a
recipient of the writer's guild of
america award and has been nominated for
multiple
emmy and canadian film awards
he has written for numerous publications
including life the new york times book
review the nation sight and sound the
new york review of books and film
quarterly
he is the author of 17 books including
steven spielberg a biography searching
for john ford which won best foreign
film book of the year from the french
film critics organization in 2008 and
frank copra the catastrophe of success
please join me in welcoming our speaker
tonight joseph mcbride
thank you matt and thank you doug
jeffrey and thank you everybody at
hillsdale for having me it's wonderful
to be here and it's a real honor and
it's been really interesting getting to
know the history of the college and
talking to all kinds of fascinating
people so thank you it's really a treat
frank capra is a subject of great
interest to me always has been of course
and
i'm teaching a course right now on capra
and howard hawks at san francisco state
which is
a great pleasure
i've been asked to talk about capra his
life and times
and since i did the biography of capra
and knew him well i also wrote the
american film institute life achievement
award tribute to capri so
i've had a lot of opportunity to
study him and his films
over
it took seven and a half years to do
this book
and
so i'll
i've written this out because it's i
want to be really precise
the screenwriter philip dunn wrote of my
frank capra biography that it was quote
the dramatic story of one of the most
interesting characters ever to emerge in
hollywood
i found that to be abundantly true
researching capra in his life and times
and writing frank capra the catastrophe
success
had to be so interesting that it took up
seven and a half years of my life
uh writing my capra biography remains
the most difficult challenge i've ever
had as a writer in part because of the
complexity of the man
and my research in separating his myth
from his reality
many people continue to have a vested
interest in maintaining the appealing
myth of capra as a liberal humanist
a lover of humanity a courageous
truth-teller in his films and his life
that unfortunately is far from the
reality
while i still admire his films in fact
even more so today because i understand
him better in the context
in which he made the films
the life of this iconic figure is in
fact a great american tragedy
it's a story much different from the one
capri tells in his largely fictitious
1971 autobiography the name above the
title
but was what was frank capra's story and
why is it so important to know the truth
about it
in brief this was a true story
capra was an immigrant from sicily who
loved america
took on this country's fiercely
competitive values won three oscars as
best director made the cover of time
magazine
and became a multi-millionaire during
the depression era he both celebrated
and criticized his adopted country in
his films
but ultimately capra was betrayed by
america which he correctly but covertly
called quote a pretty grim and bitter
payoff
capra was a champion of what we now call
auteurism
he helped lead the way for the
empowerment and celebration of directors
as the principal artists in films
he called this his one man one film
theory
the truth is that despite his tremendous
talents as a director capra was
unsatisfied with that job
he turned to it after failing as a
scientist and as a writer
he admitted to me that he wished he
could have stayed in science because he
said i would have done more
he also told me directing a picture is
almost as important as writing a book
partly as a result of his frustration
over not being the kind of genuine
author he wanted to be
he hated being dependent on his
screenwriters so he tried to deny them
the credit they were due
eventually most of the best hollywood
writers stopped working with him or he
with them since he decided he would no
longer work with liberals or leftists
and his career collapsed
when america turned on capra he blamed
his writers he blamed them for the
social commentary and criticism that
made him a major popular success during
the depression era
but then landed him in such trouble
after world war ii
when the country began regarding with
suspicion what was called premature
anti-fascism
capra was trying to shift the
responsibility but he was correct in
suggesting that the themes of his films
did largely come from his writers
especially from robert riskin a new deal
liberal who provided what we now call
the capra-esque themes of these films
philip dunn noted they could just just
as well
can ask
capra's political troubles really began
in 1939 with mr smith goes to washington
a powerful and patriotic
piece of social criticism
that much to capra's discomfort then and
later was written by a member of the
communist party sydney buckman
capra told me he considered that his
best film not its wonderful life
and i agree
he recognized the buckman script was the
best script you ever had to work with
as i discovered in my research when
capra's own loyalty was under suspicion
and the u.s government considered him
quote possibly subversive unquote
he informed on buckman and several of
his other writers to save his own skin
he fled hollywood in 1951 for his ranch
in fallbrook in effect blacklisting
himself from the film business
capra was perhaps most unhappy because
he was adulated for what he was not
he came to the sobering realization late
in life that he was admired
for quote what i stand for rather than
what i am
he had written the name above the title
to resuscitate his moribund career and
bring himself back from oblivion
in that it was a great success he
reveled in
of his youthful fans who thought he was
a liberal idealist like them
and viewed him as an inspirational
figure sort of a latter-day gandhi
not realizing that he was a political
reactionary a misanthrope and a
thorough going bigot who hated any
ethnic group you name them
jews african americans mexican americans
native americans
japanese americans irish americans even
his fellow italian americans
how could all this be the answer goes
back to capra's tortured relationship
with his writers
perhaps my most important interview
source from my book was chester stitched
capra's secretary for 39 years
if you're going to do a biography find
the secretary because they know
everything
chad
chet's judge told me that
what he thought what made capra a great
filmmaker was that in his prime he
surrounded himself with colleagues of
all different ideological persuasions he
had communists he had liberals he had
conservatives he had everything in
between
and he would listen to them and absorb a
range of viewpoints
capra's use of such a diverse brain
trust helped give the films
although it also accounts for some
incoherences in his work which expresses
a complex
and sometimes contradictory mixture of
idealism and disillusionment toward the
american social political system
that blend of love and criticism toward
his adopted country
struck a chord with capra's fellow
american
important american direct troubled
period
when our political and economic system
was in danger of collapse even though
capra told me he hated franklin d
roosevelt
because he was a rich kid capra said
but probably more because of the high
taxes of the roosevelt era
and though capra admitted in a secret
document written for the us government
in 1941 that he had voted straight
republican since 1920
which meant that he voted for
warren harding calvin coolidge and even
herbert hoover twice
capra was regarded as the spokesman for
the little guy the common man in the new
deal era
a role he accepted and did little to
discourage
capra und un undeniably had his finger
on the pulse of the american heartbeat
in the 1930s and the complex often dark
moods of his pictures from that period
continue to resonate strongly with us
today
and for all his weaknesses as a writer
and a visual stylist and a muddled
political thinker
capra most of all was a brilliant
director of actors who even if he didn't
love people in general
loved actors and managed to convey that
love on the screen making his ca his
audiences care deeply about his
characters
that to me is his most enduring and
truest legacy as an artist and a large
part of why i still love the films just
parenthetically when i was talking to
chet stitched about capra's second wife
lou
i asked what she brought to his life and
he said well she was very different from
frank she liked people and
that's one thing
and he said she was cheerful
uh capra's life was both the roaring
success at least for the first half of
his 94 years and a tragic failure
his was the story of an american icon
who was false to himself into his
professed ideals a hollow man
who ultimately felt bereft of
self-respect and full of secret contempt
for those who admired him for what he
recognized were the wrong reasons
but it was the audience he told me that
had kept him in the business long after
he wanted to quit
although he said he certainly was sorely
tempted so here are the two major
questions we need to ask ourselves about
this extraordinary life story
one even though the reality of kaeper's
life is far more interesting in every
way than the myth why do many people
prefer the myth to the reality is it
necessary to live in a state of denial
about the man to admire him as an artist
for many of his admirers it is necessary
for capra's films in many ways represent
the core democratic values of our
country
ours is also a country that tends to
foster illusions and denial of reality
rather than an honest scrutiny of its
flaws the kind of flaws capra and his
writers
examine in his best work
two how can understanding the reality as
well as the myth-making process help us
better understand the films as well as
the man himself
we cannot truly understand capra's great
films and his legacy in american culture
without coming to terms with the reality
of his life
as it was lived and with the way he and
others wanted even
desperately needed to turn it into a
caprese fairy tale
as most critics now recognize the films
are much darker than they appear on the
surface even if many capra fans remained
determinedly blind to their complexities
and contradictions
what brought me to start writing a
biography of frank capra in 1984 and set
out to excavate the truth from under the
myth
david thompson in his biographical
dictionary film refers to quote joseph
mcbride's careful and horrified
biography of capra
i say horrified because mcbride was once
a leading fan of the director
thompson evidently thought it was ironic
that i'm the one who wrote the biography
since i was once a leading fan of the
director
overlooking the fact that i'm still a
fan of capra's work maybe that's no
coincidence because as oscar wilde
quipped
every great man nowadays has his
disciples and it is usually judas who
writes the biography
although i became disillusioned the more
i came to know capra when i met him in
1975 i admired this man immensely
i was having lunch with him at a country
club near palm springs
he was giving me his big frank capra
populist rap about how he hated bankers
and rich people
a man came over to the table and said
frank here are the pictures of you
playing golf with president ford
capra said ah wonderful jerry ford is
such a great guy
in one picture president ford was
holding the pin for capra as he was
putting and i thought wow that's the
ultimate immigrant fantasy the
president's holding the pin for you
while you're putting
capra was so thrilled looking at those
pictures then the man left and capra
turned to me and said where was i oh
yeah i was telling you that i've always
had a hatred of rich people
and he continued without skipping a beat
and i suddenly realized he's not the man
he pretends to be
there's a contradiction between the
image and the man
he's not really a populist
he's someone who likes hanging out with
the power structure
or he's a schizoid character so i made a
mental note find out more
then i was asked to write the american
film institute's life achievement award
special about caprent cbs tv in 1982.
i came to know him well as i helped him
write his acceptance speech i spent two
months writing the speech with capra and
rehearsing it with him over and over
he appreciated the help and enjoyed the
process
one revealing instance i probably should
have put in my book
capra brought me some notes from the
speech in which he wanted to say
tonight i'm going to tell you this
the real secret of the whole thing the
art of frank capra
is very very simple it's the love of
people
and add two simple ideals to this love
of people the freedom of each individual
and the equal importance of each
individual and you have the formula upon
which i've based all my
films i read that over and said to capra
that it was fine except it wouldn't be
better to call it a principle rather
than a formula
he eagerly agreed so he called it the
principle on which i based all my films
part of me wishes i'd let him be more
himself and admit to him the love of
people was really just a formula
and while i was writing the show i first
had access to capra's papers at wesleyan
university in connecticut
what was most troubling to me as a capra
admirer
was that his career collapsed so
precipitously after world war ii
i was wondering why and all the books on
capra including his autobiography didn't
really explain this
he made his last good film in 1946 it's
a wonderful life
and from there on it was a headlong
plunge into terrible filmmaking
i thought there had to be a story there
i've been a journalist since 1960 and i
think of myself as essentially an
investigative reporter
and what i found was a big story one
that everyone had missed for decades
when you write for a newspaper or a
magazine you have a few days or weeks
maybe to write an article but when you
write a biography you can spend years on
a single story and do it right
like almost everyone else i pretty much
believe the name above the title
but i found strident aspects that
disturbed me in there some things that
seemed jarring
in particular there was a section about
the early 1950s during the blacklist
period
when capra was running against
communists and he was sent by the state
department to india to propaganda
propagandize against communists
that section was strange and discordant
and unpleasant but i thought when i get
to his papers i will look for the box
from 1951. so i went to wesleyan and
asked him to bring me that box
within 10 minutes i had the basic story
but it took me seven and a half years to
flesh out all the details
i had to do a great deal of research
interviewing people
going through all of capra's papers
digging through other documents and
delving into government files
and getting us army intelligence and fbi
files released which in some cases took
years of work by me and my attorney
maurice l mealy
basically what i found at wesleyan to
reveal what happened
was a document capra had written for the
us government
in 1951 he was part of a top secret
think tank project vista to plan
strategy for world war iii
he was head of motion picture production
and involved in psychological warfare
he had a security clearance but it was
taken away because he was accused of
being a communist sympathizer
some of the charges were frivolous but
one was particularly hard for him to
answer because he couldn't really deny
it quote you have for a number of years
closely associated with motion picture
writers and other individuals
reported to be or to have been members
of the communist party
the reason capra's films of the 1930s
were somewhat liberal and filled with
social criticism and populist in their
viewpoint
was that he worked with a lot of
left-wing writers including some
communists and a lot of liberals or what
came to be called fellow travelers
all this made him suspect after the war
even though capra was the most patriotic
guy you could possibly imagine meeting
he loved america and america had been
very good to him
and he was deeply devoted to america
when he was accused of being a communist
sympathizer and a subversive he felt he
had to write a long maya culpa proving
he was a good american
capra's defense against being called a
subversive was was that he basically
told the government that the writers
made me do it
uh you know they brought this liberal
point of view to my films it wasn't my
point of view
and in the self-justifying document he
informed on several of his writers
accusing them of being a communist
when i began working on my book that
story was still unknown
elia kazan publicly informed and bragged
about being an informer
declaring he did the right thing and
that's a major scandal even today an
ongoing debate about his morality and
judgment
capra turned in his writers in an
attempt to save himself and he kept that
secret for a long time
it's an intriguing moral question who's
worse the man who informs and hides the
truth or the man who informs and brags
about it
i'd say capra was the better man
a deeper one although a tragic figure
because he felt so ashamed of what he
had done that he didn't want anyone to
know about it
until he gave his papers for public
study at wesleyan
and i was fortunate to spend a lot of
time interviewing capra
while writing my biography in effect
hearing his confession about many
aspects of his life
as much as he quarreled about various
points with me arguing about what i was
learning and playing games with me to
see if i could find out
the truth he was trying to hide
at which point he would usually admit
the truth i believe she actually
welcomed the opportunity to burden
himself to some extent in our sustained
year of interviews
it's hard living a lie and somewhat
liberating to let go of your false image
i realized the
premises of kaeper scholarship were all
wrong because they were based on his
autobiography
some scholars today say well i didn't
really believe it but if you look at the
earlier books on capra they mostly
assumed he was a liberal and a new deal
sympathizer or i mean i'm sorry a
supporter
i found out that his book when you
investigated was almost a complete
fabrication from start to finish
it was good discipline for me as a
biographer to check every single fact
and take nothing at face value
one of the things that did check out was
his date of birth
i found out he actually told the truth
about his age and the name about the
title
that i took the precaution of getting
capper's birth certificate from sicily
to make sure
his book is essentially a novel about
hollywood an engaging one but a novel
as will rogers wrote in his
autobiography when you put down the good
things you ought to have done and leave
out the bad bad ones you did do well
that's memoirs
we shouldn't believe in autobiographies
in general most of them are basically
self-defensive lies
but i believed it i fell for it i was
like lord gainsford at the end of
capra's last horizon
somebody asked if he believes in
shangri-la and he says yes i believe
that i believe it because i want to
believe it
so i can understand why a lot of film
critics were seduced by kaeper's myth of
this self-made man who rose to great
success and was a
social critic who made these sentimental
films about the common man
and became a multi-millionaire in the
process they wanted to believe this very
american fairy tale
but the world had missed the truth about
capra
lynn strachey whose eminent victorians
has taught
all of us biographers a great deal
wrote a biographer has to attack his
subject in unexpected places and to
shoot a sudden revealing searchlight
into obscure recesses hitherto
undivined there were many other enduring
components there are many other enduring
components to the myth about capra one
of the strangest you keep reading even
today is that he had a degree in
chemical engineering from caltech
or troop college of technology as it was
then known
i found out he didn't have a degree in
chemical engineering as he claims in his
book he had only a general bachelor of
science degree
why is that important why is that such a
key component of his myth that people
don't want to let go of it even though i
proved otherwise
well capra claims in his book that even
though he was a chemical engineer he
couldn't get a job in that field because
it had largely dried up as a result of
the first world war ending
so he drifted into filmmaking actually
he couldn't get a chemical engineering
degree because his grades took a dive
in his junior year
due to a combination of personal factors
his father was killed in an accident
frank got a girlfriend for the first
time etc
and his realization that he couldn't
handle the advanced scientific courses
he needed to become a chemical engineer
capra also makes up a story in his book
about how he became a director without
any experience by responding to what he
called a column
in a san francisco newspaper in 1921
about a new film company
i found out through long laborious
research that capra actually had spent
years in the film industry before that
doing all kinds of low-level jobs before
he began writing and directing films
most directors have what i call creation
myths that distort their beginnings to
paint themselves as this kind of fully
formed genius
without the need for formal training
many people find that romantically
appealing
i find it far more inspiring to learn
about someone whose first job in the
film business was literally
cleaning up the horseshit at a hollywood
comedy studio as capra finally admitted
to me
went on to work his way up the ladder to
becoming a director
that's the story of genuine achievement
not the contemptuous way capra paints
his supposedly casual entry into the
business
he wrote it that way partly because he
shared the attitude of his hard-working
peasant mother
who he told me never understood
why he made all that money for just
sitting in a chair
after after he showed her mr smith goes
to washington in an attempt to impress
her she asked him
well frankie when are you going to get a
job
but the most serious myths surrounding
capra those about his political beliefs
i found that kaeper didn't actually
believe most of what his own films were
saying politically
my favorite example is that of his 1932
film american madness
capra colombia made that film about a
populist banker who loans money on
character rather than collateral
because the studio was largely financed
by the populist bank of america
formerly the bank of italy
the bank of america was in danger of
going under like so many other banks in
that period before roosevelt's election
the film written by robert riskin well
before capra was assigned to direct it
serves as propaganda for fdr's argument
that it was crucial to put your money in
a bank
to help money to help keep money
circulating rather than hoarding it as
so many people were doing out of fear
but at the same time capra was making
american madness to promote this
enlightened capitalist message
he was hoarding most of his own savings
at home under a mattress
and in safe deposit boxes because he
didn't trust banks enough to deposit his
own money in his savings again
so capra's films themselves are full of
political contradictions to give you an
example of what critics thought before i
did my research
donald willis wrote a critical study
called the films of frank capra in 1974.
he wrote depending on one's political
point of view and on what capra film or
films
or parts of capri films one is talking
about frank capra as an advocate of
communism
fascism marxism populism conservatism
mccarthyism
new dealism anti-hooverism
jingoism socialism capitalism
middle-of-the-roadism
democracy or individualism
faced with this conundrum willis
simply threw up his hands and wrote it's
no accident that there are so many
interpretations of the films
the composite capra that emerges from
these films is almost impossible to pin
down politically
i myself think the caprese films were
basically not political
that's a misleading notion i criticized
when i reviewed willis's book for
variety
but i came to understand and sympathize
with willis's confusion because any
given capper film veers from far left to
far right
and back again in less than two hours
nobody had made sense out of this people
didn't have the factual basis to write
great good critical studies of capri
because they didn't know the facts
even people who worked with capra were
confused i interviewed catherine hepburn
who starred in his 1948 political drama
state of the union
and i asked what do you think he was
politically she said she assumed he was
quite liberal
i said did you know he disliked franklin
d roosevelt who was your hero
and she said
oh dear
in another telling example you might
wonder how sydney buckman who wrote mr
smith goes to washington could have been
a member of the communist party when he
wrote that
great flag waving patriotic film
the communist party during the popular
front period had the slogan communism as
20th century americanism
they thought the best way to get people
on the side of fighting fascism
was to stress the ideas of the founding
fathers into substitution
which was kind of a radical concept and
still is today
i found an astounding interview with
buckman who told bertrand to vernier in
france in 1969
that capra was terribly suspicious of
him while he was writing the script and
suspected of him of slipping communist
propaganda into the film buckman told
capra the theme of the film was that
quote it is necessary to maintain a
vigilant attitude even when you think
you're living in a democracy
that you should refuse to surrender even
on the smallest things because their
importance can be enormous
and he said there that's my theme
capra suddenly said go get with
your theme
buckman recalled it was so sudden that i
was dumbstruck
capra tried to catch himself by saying
that he didn't believe that an artist
had to have political or social
preoccupations that he should contend
himself with entertaining the public etc
i told him how can you say that you
claim to admire dickens
the slightest line of dickens has a
precise social meaning
okay he was anti-semitic but apart from
that he tried to fight poverty the
exploitation of the poor
capra looked at me and said are you a
communist
i answered him are you a fascist
and we left it at that
this is how capra's best film was
written
so how could capper make mr smith an
american madness in other films with
such apparent passion and conviction
when he didn't truly believe in what the
films were saying
he gave an interview to variety in
february 1932 in which he said something
to evolve a great film out of outer the
depression
when that picture is made it will
inaugurate the cycle that follows in the
wake of any successful
capra also observed that as variety
paraphrased that such films were just
waiting for a director cagey enough to
capitalize in the present state of the
public mind
so part of what kappa doing was
opportunism but part was genuine he had
been searching for what he called
something to say something to make his
films more important
and he was frustrated because he didn't
know what he wanted to say
he was a talented director but he didn't
have a point of view
he had a scientific education that
hadn't adequately prepared him to be a
political artist or the kind of
pundit you become when you make major
political films and have to talk about
them in public
and he found what he wanted to say
because he met this writer named robert
riskin who was a true liberal and a man
of the people
and had not turned his back on the
people as capra had
riskin essentially gave capra the social
meaning of his films in the nineteen
early nineteen thirties
a lot of capper worshipers don't like
that i wrote that but it happens to be
true
later during the blacklist era after
capra became scared about being accused
of being a subversive he deliberately
said i'll never work with another
liberal again because it'll get me in
trouble
so he started working mainly with miles
connolly
a rather insane right winger who starred
steered capra off into his blinkered
fantasies many of which never got filmed
connolly had been contributed to
contributing to capri films long before
that
i found the shooting script of mr smith
with capra's handwritten revisions he
had taken buckman's script and with
connolly's nocturnal
assistants had written in some right
wing lines here and there
suddenly gene arthur will say something
right-wing and i'd wondered well where
this was coming from well it came from
capra and connolly who were nervous
about buckman
so they stuck this stuff into the film
connolly's 1928 novel mr blue an
allegory about a modern christ figure
was a major early influence on capra's
thinking you can find many of capra's
themes in that book
capra's over-reliance on connolly in his
later years and capra's growing
obsession with trying to make films with
overtly
religious themes such as the life of
saint paul starring frank sinatra
that's a film i'd really like to see
we're among the major reasons his career
collapsed
but these were symptoms not the actual
disease capra accuses himself in his
book of cowardice
he identified that cowardice as being
afraid to gamble anymore and of losing
his independence by selling his
production company liberty films
to paramount he didn't tell his readers
why he sold out and how he
not paramount abandoned projects he had
been working on with leftist writers he
then informed upon
including michael wilson and ian
mcclellan hunter
he also informed on buckman
hugo butler herbert j bieberman and
others
capra didn't explain why he ran away
from hollywood out of fear
the opening line of charles dickens's
david carperfield is whether i shall
turn out to be the hero of my own life
or whether that station will be held by
anybody else these pages must show
when i first read that line as a
youngster i thought it was the stupidest
thing i'd ever heard
who else could be the hero of your own
life
but now i realize how profound that
question is and the hero my biography of
frank capra is not capri but michael
wilson
that blacklisted writer capra betrayed
was the man who wrote the final draft of
its wonderful life
and wrote a screenplay of friendly
persuasion for capra which capra
abandoned because of its pacifist theme
michael wilson was a man who stood firm
for his principles and paid the price
for upholding the constitutional
right to freedom of speech and political
beliefs
those principles capra's films
supposedly uphold
michael wilson was the man cap frank
happens should have been and wished he
was but wasn't
capra betrayed his own ideals and those
of his adopted country which helped make
him what philip dunn called one of the
most interesting
characters ever to emerge in hollywood
and capra was racked with secret guilt
he was ashamed of what he had done
it tormented him and ate him up made him
into a different man
it made him hate hollywood
and he was very angry toward the united
states for betraying
betraying him after all he had done for
our country
he was filled with self-loathing
i found a shocking letter he wrote in
1971 attacking his fans privately to
somebody he knew
implying that he felt they're all a
bunch of idiots basically because they
believe all this nonsense that my films
are saying
and they think i'm a wonderful guy and
they have no idea and they're a bunch of
and they're a bunch of fools
so he couldn't enjoy the success he had
earned with the young left-wing or
liberal people who rediscovered his
films in the 60s and 70s because
he secretly didn't believe in those
films and he despised his admirers
to find the deepest roots of capra's
informing i had to dig way back into his
past
graham greene wrote in the lost boyhood
of judas christ was betrayed
so i set out to reconstruct that lost
boyhood of capra
most film biographies until then barely
bothered with the early years
skipping quickly past them and
interviewing only movie stars not
civilians as we call them but i tracked
down and interviewed many people who
knew capra and his youth friends
neighbors schoolmates you couldn't do it
today because they're all gone
i had to get the names and places of his
youth from the 1910 u.s census and other
sources because capper claimed he
couldn't remember where he had lived
the story was very much different from
the way he portrayed it scheduling in
the name about the title
he wrote that he lived in a sleazy
sicilian ghetto in los angeles and he
scorned ghetto dwellers as moochers
in fact his was a multi-ethnic
neighborhood of hard-working people who
were bothered by what he wrote about
them
the most formative period for his social
viewpoint was at manual arts high school
his classmates who included general
jimmy doolittle for example were not a
bunch of bums and outcasts as he claims
in his book
they were mostly middle class wasps
going to manual arts was actually a step
up the social ladder for capra
i tried to find everybody i i could who
knew him as a boy and i interviewed 18
people who went to high school with him
kappa tried to tell me oh high school
it was great and the kids were great i
interviewed all these old people and
they said yeah everybody was wonderful
it was really nice
but most of them also said i don't
really remember capra which i found odd
a friend of mine wisely said well that's
the story isn't it
finally i found the 17th person esther
gleason schlinger
who was the historian of their class she
and frank had mutual interest in music
and photography and she had actually
dated him but her mother broke it up
because he was an immigrant esther
schlinger told me i don't know that
anybody really liked him he was
ostracized
people never invited him anywhere
because he was a foreigner they didn't
think of including him
in their parties
he was a nice boy he was just a terrible
whop
when i heard that ethnic slur
came to see his true role in american
life it all clicked into place
i asked kaeper about this and he
confirmed the story he said the kids had
treated him badly because he was an
immigrant
and he had to wear cheap clothes and get
to school early to clean the blackboards
when i when i uncovered that part of the
story it gave me greater empathy for the
way capra had been treated and for the
suffering and humiliation he went
through as an immigrant in america
it gave me more admiration for his
determination to succeed he wanted to
show them
by getting an education and fighting his
way to the top ruthless as he may have
been along the way
what i was finding out kept deepening my
view of capra and showing me what a
remarkably complex man he was
with all his faults and virtues and his
emblematic qualities as an outsider to
america who became our most passionate
one of our most passionate spokesman
and then was kicked in the teeth by the
country he loved
to borrow othello's words in shakespeare
capra was one who loved not wisely but
too well
capra was somebody whose tragedy was in
denying his background denying who he
was to get ahead in america
it was the time of the pernicious
melting pot myth
that discouraged pride in your ethnic
roots and capra wanted to be more
american than anyone else
not only was he a bigot he even despised
his own family because there are
immigrants who spoke with broken accents
so he rejected them and he destroyed
himself in the process this is a
cautionary tale
i believe that studying an artist's
biography is important to understanding
how his or her creative process and
worldview were formed
that is not an entirely popular view
in academic film studies biography is
often viewed with suspicion as is the
entire idea of authorship
even though ironically many film studies
courses are built around the work of
auteur directors
and the biographical enterprise is also
seen as suspect by some in the popular
media
who evidently prefer hagiography
joyce carol oates coined that awful
derogatory term pathobiography
she thinks it's terrible that
biographies deal on dwell on people's
flaws
that seems awfully naive to me
who can i quote better than the subject
of the greatest biography ever written
dr samuel johnson who said
if a man is to write a panda jirek he
may keep vices out of sight but if he
professes to write a life
he must represent it
really as it was
and lynton strait she writes that the
duty of the biographer is to maintain
his own freedom of spirit
it is not his business to be
complimentary it is his business to lay
bear the facts of the case as he
understands them
so we need accurate portraits to be able
to understand great artists and to truly
understand capra's films
and then we have the basis for writing
good critical studies once we have the
facts about his life and career
ingmar bergman said that what makes
someone a great film director is that he
or she has a personal vision
capra had such a vision but it was
actually robert riskin's first and to
some extent miles connelly's
capra blended their viewpoints and
adopted that as his personal vision
my biographies of directors are both
tourist and anti-a tourist it's been
said they contain an unresolved tension
because they debunk auteurism yet read
the works as autobiographical
and i plead guilty to this that's an
accurate contradiction
i think that's part of the collaborative
filmmaking process
you get things from all over if you're a
filmmaker and if you're a strong
director
somehow make them your own and make them
autobiographical
capra was able to get his liberal themes
from robert riskin exalting the common
man
even if capra himself had a reactionary
wariness of the people on mass
capricor tap into the more generous risk
and perspective because he too had been
a common man at the beginning
even though he later turned his back on
the people he still could viscerally
feel what it was like for them and care
about the common man
even though he was voting for herbert
hoover
so your mind and your heart operate in
different ways perhaps the most
important lesson of biography
the deepest fascination of the genre is
that people have parts and they're often
contradictory
and you have to accept that
i often think of what william butler
yates wrote we make out of the quarrel
with others
rhetoric but of the quarrel with
ourselves poetry
i continue to be fascinated with
studying the mixture of rhetoric and
poetry that results from these quarrels
and the lives and works of great film
directors
so that's why i wrote frank capra's
biography and why i believe it's
important to understand the real frank
capra
as well as the myth and how and why that
seductive myth was created thank you
thank you joe mcbride we have some time
for questions uh if you'd like to raise
your hand we have a microphone here and
a microphone that will be over here
please raise your hand and stand up when
the microphone is brought to you and
wait for the microphone to be brought to
you
thank you very much for a very good
presentation on frankie
and
the life surrounding his films
i really appreciated that thank you um
having to do with the style of frank
capra
i see a lot in his films that we miss
today in films there's a lot of great
directors out there a lot of technical
achievements
but the style of frank capra in his film
seemed to be very
distinct
and as i would compare
watching today say
capra's films from last night today
mr smith goes to washington on and on
compared to like uh hitchcock's style
hitchcock was very
precise
yet it seemed in capra his sets
the way he would shoot it was much more
loosey-goosey
much more
where you could really identify with a
character as if they were there were
real characters
even though they were less precise
would that be an accurate
comparison or what do you feel on that
part of his style yeah i agree um
hitchcock is a great director he was
very controlled as you say and he
he was a little i watched him shoot for
three days i had that privilege and i
saw him improvising he it's sort of a
myth that hitchcock
didn't improvise and he was actually a
good director of actors he would respect
the actors
but he planned a lot out he didn't draw
every shot like people think that's a
myth he drew out his action sequences
and special effects sequences but
there's nobody who's been more
controlling than hitchcock
capra was more
attentive to the people on the set and
and
as i tried to explain it's a paradox of
his films he loved actors deeply and
they loved him but he didn't like people
in general
uh which was you know strange
contradiction but it's true
so um some there's some pictures of him
directing like there's a
you saw you can't take it with you today
there's a picture of him directing that
scene with lionel barrymore and jean
arthur in her bedroom when
he's he's asking if she loves jimmy
stewart and he's very kind toward her
and
the two actors are smiling broadly and
there's a beautiful shot of capra
sitting on the side with his wonderful
smile on his face he had a great
smile and warmth when you
met him although he could turn really
cold too but
you know that's what directors do
but it was all for the actors he he
believed in the actors as the most
important people in film as did say
orison wells
and he was he was a very good technician
in some ways but technique was not his
concern
and i think when we go to today's films
a lot of them are all about technique
and
uh very very little about people
you have the transformers movies which
are about giant pieces of metal banging
into each other and
you know even if they took the trouble
to have
the robots look a little different you
could maybe care about the robots but
you know i once talked to capra about
he told me he liked american graffiti
which i thought oh okay that makes sense
it's a good movie about people and it's
a lot like a wonderful life
and then he said he liked star wars and
i said well wait a minute i thought you
said you like people movies it's about
robots and he said yeah but the great
achievement of that film was lucas made
the robots seem like people
you know and so
so that's what you get from capri films
that
warmth and
love of people that comes across between
him and his actors and
there is a kind of a
spontaneity i think where he would
spot something happening with an actor
and he would go for it and cut to a
close-up
i see that in true foes films as well
that suddenly there's a
big close-up of somebody with a
tremendous emotional reaction i i'll
mention barbara stanwick who's one of
the stars that he discovered and
she was the kind of actor who gave it
all in her first take
and she was not so good in the following
take so
as one of his crew members said the
first tank take with stanwood was
sacrosanct you had to get it
so you would have multiple cameras
with her and she would do some big
emotional scene
and um if you blew it you were you were
gone literally there was a guy named
freddy kaifer who was the cameraman on
capra's film rain or shine and they had
a fire scene where a circus tent caught
on fire and freddie keefer was up on a
platform with the camera and the
platform collapsed and freddie keefer
bravely threw his arms around the camera
to protect the camera
and went down with the camera and was
very seriously injured and it was in the
hospital for an entire year
and then capra rehired him to do a
barbara stanweight film the miracle
woman
which starts with her giving an
impassioned sermon and freddie keefer
was one of the cameramen
and he missed a capra would let stanwick
not hit the marks like some directors
would insist you hit the marks and she
could move wherever she wanted according
to her
emotion and you had to catch it
freddie keefer missed one of her moves
and capra fired him
kind of cold as the members thought but
that's how important barbara stanwick's
emotions were to capra
so everything was about the actress he
was not a particularly good visual
stylist if you look at his films
before joseph walker came along
they're very undistinguished visually
and then after joseph walker
who
last filmed with kaeper was it's a
wonderful life the film's become very
drab and
the cameraman of the film after that
told me he was very frustrated because
capper would never talk to him about the
visuals
he had no no visual ideas and his films
became very
mediocre after that
so it was all about the actors and the
story and the the message you know i
hope that explains some of that
but walker was a great cameraman and as
leonard malton said he ground lenses
for his actresses he was known as a
great
cinematographer of women he made barbara
stanwick a star partly by understanding
how to film
this unusual looking actress and he made
jean arthur a star with the beautiful
lighting he did and he had like eight
gene arthur lenses and nine barbara
stanwyck lenses and
amazing guy so yeah another question
that was a good question
yeah so
i was just wondering when he squealed on
the rest of the liberal
filmmakers or
not filmmakers writers
i'm wondering what were they doing
that could get them in trouble
besides
potentially subversive films
and what happened to them
did they get
in any real trouble or would they just
watch yeah well the blacklist was
intended to root out communist influence
in hollywood and there were communist
writers and some communist directors in
hollywood they didn't have an awful lot
of influence on content because the
studios
wouldn't let a communist
film be made in hollywood you know but
they did put a certain liberalism and
leftism occasionally in the films mr
smith goes to washington is actually
quite a strong
criticism of corruption in our
government and
um
you know a ringing defense of
our freedoms which some people take for
granted or don't like our you know the
first amendment is not terribly popular
today so sydney buckman the communist
writer helped put that into the film
but um a lot of the blacklist was aimed
at liberals trying to scare liberals or
people who flirted with liberal ideas
they blacklisted about 300 people which
means they couldn't work anymore
mostly communists or communist
sympathizers who
very kafka ask you could be
accused of something without knowing who
is accusing you or what
what you might have done and
you know it's always been legal in
america to be a communist or member of
any political party
as long as you don't try to overthrow
the government that's what the supreme
court
says you can't do but you can say you
can speak your mind say whatever you
want write whatever you want and the
marketplace will decide if they want to
buy it
um
but
a lot of these people couldn't work
anymore and some of them came back years
later they lost a lot of years of their
lives some of them committed suicide a
lot of them
wound up doing
crummy jobs
their families broke up all kinds of
damage was left in the wake of this
the defense of some of the informers was
i informed only on people who had been
named before but every
every naming sent messages out to the
network of people who were blacklisting
people such as ronald reagan and john
wayne and ward bond and people like
hetta hopper
it was really the studios who
blacklisted people too not the
government actually the studios caved in
and panicked and refused to hire these
people and so
capra naming writers was
damaging even though he did it in secret
and i also found a letter where he said
he had
informed to the fbi many times on the
loyalty of others
the local fbi so he was an fbi informant
and he was also a state department
informant helping to clear people for
government
projects so he was like to protect
himself he was turning in all kinds of
his colleagues and friends which is a
very ignoble thing to do
and uh it didn't save him from from
being run out of town he was
tired with the the guilt by association
as they called it
and we call that the mccarthy era he
actually came along later and he didn't
investigate hollywood but
he was he was a master of guilt by
association if you worked with a
communist you had to be suspect
you know even if mr smith goes to
washington is a great patriotic film
you worked with a communist capra
said he was a communist
this is the way it worked it was a very
evil ugly time in america and it still
affects us i didn't realize this until i
started working as a screenwriter in
hollywood one reason films are so bad
today
is that people are terribly afraid of
political themes i tried to sell a lot
of political projects
in hollywood and i was told
like i had i wanted to do a film about
the bay of pigs invasion which has never
been filmed and that would make a great
movie and my agent said oh you can't do
that and i said why and she said well
it's political
and you know that's that's the attitude
a lot of people have so when when a
political film gets made today
it takes a strong daring filmmaker like
spielberg or oliver stone or somebody or
clint eastwood
who has the clout to make a film like
that uh the films today are quite timid
compared to the capra films and the
films that john ford and other people
made in the 30s and 40s
which was really a better period so it's
worth reading up on the blacklist i
would recommend victor navaski's book
naming names if you want to read a good
you know one volume book that tells you
a lot about the blacklist and all the
complicated moral issues that were
involved
more questions this will be our final
question
thank you mr mcbride um could you touch
on uh
frank capra's spiritual life or possibly
even lack thereof
yeah he was a very christian filmmaker
his films are full of christian
iconography their
heroes are often christ figures and um
he was a
complicated guy he was like by birth but
he drifted away from catholicism
christian scientist for a while because
his first wife who is jewish was also
christian scientist
and then he
after the blacklist he
experienced a conversion he was
panicking because his values were in
turmoil
and he went back to the catholic church
in the 50s and and
married his wife in the catholic church
and he became very very
overtly religious it was fine and mr
smith goes to washington mr deeds to
portray
characters as christ-like
sacrificial
noble figures who are crucified for
their beliefs that that plays well
dramatically but what
got capra into trouble was he was trying
to do a lot of religious kind of
propaganda films which don't tend to get
made in hollywood they were making bible
movies and
lives of certain saints and stuff but i
read all of these projects and they're
almost all really awful
unfortunately uh
preachy and kind of dull and
tedious uh he made most of his later
projects that hollywood turned down were
religious propaganda and kind of
embarrassing
there was one that i liked called the
carpenter of god that he commissioned
john fante to write
who's a very good writer is about saint
joseph my namesake
and the whole idea was that here's this
guy who marries a virgin a woman who
tells him she's a virgin
and then one day she comes and says by
the way i'm pregnant and
while he's taking that in she says oh
the father is actually uh
god and this angel came and told me i
was pregnant and
this ordinary carpenter has to kind of
come to terms with this
wild situation
and so it's a very
not a satirical film but it was a
serious film about
what an ordinary person might do in a
situation like that how you how you
do you believe this or do you how do you
handle this you know and it was a really
interesting film and he wanted to make
it as a television movie starring danny
thomas who you know might have been good
but the legion of decency had to pass on
those things and the
monsignor who passed on these films said
in no way can you do this because this
sheds doubt on the virgin birth you know
and that's unfortunate here capra was
trying to make a you know serious
religious film and
shot down by the catholic church but the
studios weren't going for his life of
saint paul with frank sinatra which as i
say would would have would have been a
one-of-a-kind film
frank sinatra was kind of like saint
paul in some ways he was a sinner and
it would have been a rat pack religious
movie i think um
and then he wanted to make a movie with
elvis presley which was where presley
would become a
political demagogue this rock singer was
used as a demagogue and that would have
been an interesting script that
presley's manager colonel parker said in
no way we're going to have elvis be a
fascist demagogue you know so some of
the capri later films would have been
interesting and he was trying
but it's a terribly frustrating
record to read all these things i can't
believe i actually read 11 drafts of
maroon for example which capra was going
to direct and
jimmy stewart turned him down that was
kind of the end for capra when he
offered jimmy stewart whose career he
had made
an important part in marooned and jimmy
stewart turned him down and capra's
diary says i
i went to bed for the day
and i asked jimmy stewart about this and
he said i don't remember that you know
but it was not a time when capra's kind
of films were fashionable either they
they were seen as old-fashioned but he
had really lost his ability
unfortunately because he had lost his
self-confidence as an artist and he said
once and to me and other people
that
he
lost the ability to make decisions
and he said that's all a director does
is make a thousand decisions a day
people are coming up to you and they
said you want
this proper that proper do you want to
act over here over here do you want this
actor that actor and
he couldn't make decisions and i
realized that that was a function of the
blacklist
michael wilson i found a note in his
papers he said why do informers
have to make themselves out as idiots
and that's a really interesting question
when you
when you compromise your moral beliefs
whatever they are
you lose your ability to make decisions
because you're afraid of the
consequences
and maybe since you feel ashamed of
yourself you don't you you don't want to
make those decisions because of the
damage you've caused yourself and
other people so capra really
hurt himself very badly and in effect
black
if he had stayed in hollywood he might
have been
blacklisted or greylisted greylisted was
this horrible category where you weren't
sure if you were blacklisted or not
and also the blacklist
blacklisting was illegal in california
and the producers hired james burns who
was
i found this out in
a lot of secret papers
he was truman secretary of state and he
advised them
to deny the blacklist existed because if
they admitted it they could be sued
so they said there is no blacklist so
it's like holocaust denial it's bad
enough being a holocaust victim
but to be told that the holocaust didn't
happen is another
horrible blow
as late as the 1970s ronald reagan did
an interview for a film and he said
there was no such thing as the blacklist
in hollywood so a lot of people even
though i came up with
all the facts about capra after many
years of work and i
printed the appendix in my book
some of the actual document he wrote
informing on people
a lot of people don't mention this they
don't bring it up it's kind of not
brought up as one of the reasons capra's
career collapsed but i concluded that
that is really the reason
that this great american director
totally fell apart overnight almost and
it's it's a horrible tragedy but
a great story that i felt i had a great
story and
but the films remain and i just want to
leave you with this point that i'm still
a big capra fan and this semester when
i'm teaching capra
it's brought back to me how wonderful
his films were i just showed the miracle
woman and
today i saw you can't take it with you
and yesterday
it happened one night and the audience
loved all these films and the students
were
really into the films they played well
for
people who weren't born way back then
and as leonard walton said the jokes are
still
paying off at the same places where
capra put them in the films and there's
a real warmth in humanity in these films
that we could
learn from so
even though his
life was
half a success and half of failure the
successes were many and
and wonderful and so we cling to the
the great works that he left behind us
and i would recommend mr smith goes to
washington and mr deeds goes to town and
and his early
columbia films are wonderful too
all different kinds of films before he
discovered what it was to be capra-esque
so thank you for coming and thank you
again to everybody at hillsdale for
having me
you